Ladies and gentlemen, it's hard to believe
25 years ago this week
my first guest was elected the 42nd president
of the United States,
which led to the longest period of peace time expansion
in American history.
We are honored
to have him join us here in Harlem tonight.
Please welcome, President Bill Clinton!
(audience cheering)
(jazzy music)
Whoa.
(audience cheering loudly)
So...
You were great at Sylvia's.
You think I have a future at Sylvia's,
is that what you're saying?
I do.
But I have one question.
Did they let you keep the hairnet?
(Conan laughing)
That's not a good look for me.
It's really not a good look for me.
It was so cool.
Look, it's a great place.
[Conan] Yes, you've been there?
You've eaten there quite--
Oh yes.
many times.
It's great.
Yeah.
And they're great people.
Yep.
And it's part of what makes Harlem special.
My office is two blocks from here.
[Conan] Yeah, yeah.
It's great.
It's amazing.
I couldn't believe in the introduction,
you were elected president,
time does strange things,
25 years ago this week.
And the first question I had was,
what was the hardest thing to get used to
on the first day that you were no longer president,
as a civilian, 'cause that's gotta be a massive change.
What was the hardest thing to get used to?
They don't play a song when you walk in the room anymore.
(audience laughing)
I mean, it's amazing.
(Conan laughing)
For three or four weeks, I was totally lost.
I didn't know where I was.
I was, "Where is Hail to the Chief?"
I kept thinking--
You could probably work it out so they play it for you.
You get a little boombox and just push a button
when you come into a room.
Yeah, but then, if you think you're still there,
that's a really dangerous thing.
(Conan laughing)